[Applaudissements]
l'esplanade des mosquées est en feu
symbole d'une journée sous très haute
tension
ce lundi soir le ton est encore monté
entre israéliens et palestiniens depuis
gaza
les militants du hamas ont d'abord lancé
des roquettes en direction de la ville
sainte jérusalem riposte d'israël
frappes de représailles et un bilan
lourd au moins 20 morts dont neuf
enfants à gaza
dans les deux camps aucun signe
d'apaisement au contraire ce soir en
cette journée de jérusalem
les organisations terroristes de gaza
ont franchi une ligne rouge et nous ont
attaqués à l'aide de missiles sur la
périphérie de jérusalem israël répondra
avec une grande force on ne tolèrerons
aucune attaque sur notre territoire sur
notre capital sur nos citoyens et sur
nos soldats quiconque nous attaquent
paiera un lourd tribut je vous le dis
citoyens d'israël
le conflit actuel pourrait se poursuivre
pendant un certain temps nous ne
cherchons pas l'escaladent mais
quiconque choisit cette option
ressentira le poids de notre bras ce
qu'il se passe à jérusalem est un appel
au meurtre et exprime l'esprit de
criminalité de haine qui s'exprime dans
l'éducation des partis en israël dans
l'éducation scolaire et les programmes
d'enseignement
j'appelle la communauté internationale à
intervenir immédiatement pour mettre un
terme à ces violations horrible et à
protéger les citoyens les territoires
palestiniens surtout à jérusalem qui
subi un nettoyage ethnique
aujourd'hui jérusalem redonne de l'éclat
à la cause palestinienne
la communauté internationale appelle
désormais à une désescalade
alors que les prochaines heures
s'annoncent tout aussi chaotique